Obi-Wan have you done as i
asked have you trained the boy
Welcome back everyone this will be my obi-wan
kenobi qui-gon jin video a lot of you asking if
liam neeson is going to have a cameo scene in the
series there's been a couple of scenes directly
referencing him so far during the episodes so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos we're doing a giveaway for disney plus
memberships all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and post all your qui-gon jinn cameo
scene theories on the video if ever i needed
guidance master it's now master quicker master
there is always hope my friend though it often
comes and forms not looked for the key is knowing
how to see it and seizing that opportunity i have
been tasked with guiding you forward but during
the events of episode 1 and episode 2 there are
two different big qui-gon jinn references and you
remember previously in the timeline during revenge
of the sith yoda specifically told obi-wan kenobi
when they were last together on bail organa
ship dividing the twins up to hide them
that while he was busy watching over a young
luke skywalker which we've seen so far he had
a mission for him new jedi training and yoda was
going to teach obi-wan in their remaining time
together on that ship how to commune with qui-gon
jinns for spirit and that qui-gon specifically
had learned the secrets of life after death an
old friend has learned the path to immortality
qui-gon how to commune with him i will teach you
what he meant obviously without saying it exactly
was qui-gon had learned the secrets of how to
become a force ghost from the priestesses of the
wills before his death and they wanted obviously
preserve the canon because during a new hope movie
you see obi-wan kenobi turning into a four
spirit returning during empire strikes back
for the first time as an actual four spirit luke
is all surprised like wait a minute what are you
doing here what had happened though is earlier in
the timeline when qui-gon jinn was younger before
his death he found the priestesses of the wills in
the wellspring of life this special planet in the
galaxy shrouded in mystery that was supposed
to be hidden from star maps kind of the same
way it was almost impossible for anyone to
find and reach mortis or the world between
worlds just different special places in the force
around the galaxy that was really hard to find
inyoda wanted obi-wan to learn how to become
a force ghost from qui-gon jinn's force spirit
like qui-gon specifically would teach him how
to become a force ghost in the time between the
obi-wan series where we're seeing right now and
then a new hope movie but first yoda had to teach
obi-wan how to speak with qui-gons for spirits
specifically the reason why yoda was doing this is
because previously qui-gon held helped yoda find
the shaman of the will so that yoda himself could
fully learn how to become a force ghost and yoda
was able to complete the training before he died
in a way that qui-gon jinn was not able to do they
covered all that during the clone wars it is i
contin that cannot be dead you are
now i am part of the living force yoda
the reason why qui-gon wasn't able to become a
full-force ghost like you see yoda obi-wan anakin
skywalker luke skywalker even leia later in the
timeline is because he was killed by darth maul
during the events of phantom menace before he
could complete his training with the shaman of
the wills during episode 1 and episode 2 obi-wan
kenobi specifically calls out for qui-gon jinn's
help asking for guidance he's meant to be at his
lowest point here emotionally spiritually within
the force when the series picks up like he has no
hope for the future the series is all about how he
finds that again in young luke skywalker young
lei in what remains of the spark inside anakin
skywalker within darth vader thus the title of the
next movie a new hope so on a certain level they
want to preserve the canon so he has to learn to
become a force ghost and qui-gon jin is the person
that does that for him a lot of you also asking
if obi-wan kenobi was able to meet with the force
ghost of qui-gon jinn before and he talked about
being a force spirit consciousness after death
how come he's not thinking about it later in
the timeline here during the obi-wan series or
when yoda is talking to him in revenge of the sith
like he treats it as if it's a brand new idea like
wait a minute qui-gon still alive i can learn more
things from him force ghost what are you talking
about way earlier in the timeline they traveled
to mortis which is the special area inside the
force where they're like literally communing with
avatars of the living force themselves it's meant
to be this huge nexus of the force this very
ethereal place where different aspects of the
force are at war with each other like the light
side the dark side the balance between them so
you have the father the daughter and the son
and it's all about them exploring the idea that
anakin skywalker is this child of prophecy this
child literally of the force what kind of balance
is he going to bring is he going to destroy the
galaxy is he going to help lead it to this new age
which side of the force needs the most balancing
so to speak and while this is happening while
anakin skywalker and the others are going
through this big trial inside the special
force nexus the spirit of qui-gon jinn is able
to speak literally to obi-wan kenobi and commune
with him in a physical way that a lot of other
traditional force spirits are in the normal world
qui-gon how are you here i am here because you are
here he mostly spends the time talking to obi-wan
about the prophecy itself mostly talking about
anakin skywalker but it's like your first big clue
about having life after death about becoming an
actual forced spirit because it's happening before
yoda learns to become a force ghost the reason
why obi-wan kenobi seems like he forgets about
it later in the timeline during revenge of this is
because everything that happens within this forced
nexus of mortis is meant to be like this very
special one-off thing like all these crazy things
are only able to happen because they're inside
this special place so obi-wan doesn't necessarily
think that they're able to exist outside in the
real world which is what yoda is telling him no
no no he's actually able to manifest here in the
real world but i have to teach you how to commune
with qui-gon spirit so there are a lot of specific
rules about who is able to become a force ghost
how it works what exactly they can do when
they become force ghosts the first big thing
is that only light side jedi can actually become
traditional force ghosts sith can't do it the same
way that you see yoda or the other characters
become force ghosts now there is the classic
tale of darth plagueis the wise did you ever
hear the tragedy of darth plagueis the wise
darth sidious former master darth plagueis learned
the sith version of eternal life which is a little
bit different but kind of related they use
different methods to achieve something close
to the same result but it's not exactly the
same thing what the emperor was talking about
during revenge of the sith was using his clones
to transfer your force essence to essentially
retain eternal life but he was also talking about
influencing the midichlorians themselves so that
you could retain your consciousness as a forced
spirit like anakin was trying to find a way to get
the midichlorians to just freeze padme so that
she wouldn't die and even though the emperor's
manipulating him in this scene he's trying to tell
him what he wants to hear technically the sith
version of life after death isn't exactly what
anakin thinks that it is in this moment but again
both for jedi and for sith is about retaining
your consciousness after you shed your physical
form force ghosts are essentially just the former
consciousness of a jedi though without physical
form existing on a different plane if a sith
tries something like this to retain their life
or consciousness after death they either have to
bind their consciousness to an object like a sith
holocron which you've seen in the canon before
or they have to straight up possess another body
with their essence like a clone body the way that
the emperor did what happens when a jedi becomes a
force ghost is that after their physical body is
destroyed or they're killed their consciousness
travels to the nether world of the force kind
of like the star wars version of the afterlife
where most people's consciousness just becomes one
with the force again like everything you are just
combines with everything else but with proper
training and ability people like yoda obi-wan
qui-gon are able to retain their minds their sense
of self and they're able to use the living force
like the midichlorians flowing through the cosmic
force to travel around the galaxy wherever they
want speak to whoever they want do whatever they
want the living forces like the midichlorians the
biological essence of the force that permeate all
living things at the microscopic level the cosmic
force is like the connective tissue that connects
all of them across the galaxy and represents the
sort of will of the force it's like the conduit
that the force ghosts use to travel around the
galaxy when you become a full force ghost you have
a limited ability to interact with the world but
you can use the force and physically interact with
things like yoda is able to call down a lightning
strike with the force and luke skywalker is
able to physically grasp anakin skywalker's
lightsaber hilt but it takes a tremendous amount
of power and will for them to do stuff like that
and they can't maintain it indefinitely
like holding a semi-physical form like that
isn't something that they could do forever when
you become a full force ghost you can appear to
anyone you want you can be seen by anyone you want
to see or hear you you don't need special training
to talk to actual force ghosts like later in the
timeline after yoda's death he could actually show
up to an older version of grogu as a force
ghost anytime he wanted and commune with him
the only reason in this scene here that yoda is
talking about teaching obi-wan how to commune with
qui-gon jin's for spirit is because qui-gon
himself wasn't able to fully become a force
ghost his training was incomplete he could only
exist as this disembodied voice show yourself
can you i cannot my training was incomplete all
energy from the living force from all things
that have ever lived feeds into the cosmic force
under normal circumstances like walking around the
real world you'd only be able to hear his voice
speaking to you like when anakin skywalker was
killing all the tuscan raiders back during attack
of the clones you hear qui-gon's voice calling out
to him through the force trying to tell him to
stop that was similar to what it would be like
for obi-wan when he's learning from qui-gon to
become a force ghost a lot of you now asking how
was anakin skywalker able to become a force ghost
if he had been sith right up until his death and
we never actually saw him training with anyone
to become a force ghost and it was a very special
technique that only very powerful jedi with a lot
of training could actually achieve the way they
actually explain this at least canonically unless
they change it or retcon it later on is because
darth vader anakin skywalker turned back to the
light side just before his death acted selflessly
after he died when his essence traveled to the
netherworld of the force yoda and the others
were able to teach him to finish becoming a
force ghost retain his essence before he kind
of been completely reabsorbed into the force so to
speak also because anakin had specifically been a
child of the midichlorians themselves like he'd
literally been conceived by the force he had a
much greater connection to the force and it was
much easier for him to retain his consciousness
after death and use the living force the cosmic
force to be a force ghost now a lot of you are
also asking if it was so easy for him to pull this
off where it was really hard for other jedi why
haven't we seen way more anakin skywalker force
ghost cameo scenes in the past hayden christensen
did talk about coming back during the ahsoka
series and i think that that's where we would see
force ghost anakin because every time ahsoka has
talked about the jedi order order 66 with grogu
the other mandalorian characters she's usually
referenced anakin skywalker in some way she was
his padawan she had a much closer relationship
with him than with obi-wan kenobi or yoda
so right now in terms of qui-gon jin cameo scenes
my early theory is that they'll wait to the
obi-wan kenobi finale like episode six and they'll
probably just show him coming back to tatooine to
continue watching over luke skywalker building
his hut eventually like okay i'll stop living in
a cave i'll actually build a real hut here and
once he regains some of his inner peace like he
sort of rebalances himself from the force that's
when he'll actually start communing with qui-gon's
force spirit and we'll get our actual liam neeson
cameo scene but everyone posts all your theories
about liam neeson cameo scenes during actual
obi-wan kenobi episodes my full obi-wan kenobi
episode 3 video will post next after they release
it while you wait for that click here for my brand
new mandalorian season 3 trailer video breakdown
and ahsoka trailer breakdown and click here for my
obi-wan kenobi episode videos i'll update the
link for episode three as soon as i post that
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!